oh
Mario plus Rabbids Sparks of Hope is an
improvement over its predecessor in
every way in one of the best modern
Mario spin-offs Against All Odds Mario
plus Rabbids Kingdom battle was a
charmingly weird success fusing Nintendo
Megastar mascot Mario with ubisoft's
less than inspiring little rabbit
oddballs and throwing them into a
turn-based strategy game of all things
it was an open question then whether
Ubisoft which took the lead on the
project would be able to capture the
ineffable Nintendo magic while borrowing
some of the company's most iconic
characters with that question now
answered Mario plus rabid Sparks of Hope
sets its sights higher managing not only
to be a surprisingly good Mario spin-off
but legitimately be better than some of
Nintendo's own recent games starring the
Plucky plumber
foreign
[Music]
like the original Mario plus Rabbids
Sparks of Hope is very strange it
occupies a parallel version of the
Mushroom Kingdom where Mario and his
friends casually socialize with their
rabid doppelgangers and where many of
them are packing heat albeit in an
abstract bubblegum package the Rabbids
are a little obnoxious and off-putting
but Mario and his friends seem too
polite to say anything when they
discover a spark a new life form that is
obviously a rabbit infused with one of
Rosalina's Lumas they immediately know
something must be wrong because Rosalina
would never allow that to happen to her
babies the implicit acknowledgment that
being a rabid mutant is a terrible fate
got a good chuckle out of me right from
the jump this is indicative of how
Ubisoft approaches the overall tone
reverent and respectful of Mario lore
such as it is while cheeky and
self-aware about its own rabbit's
Creations Mario and his friends are
video game royalty and its cast includes
a literal space goddess the Rabbids were
always made to be annoying that was sort
of the joke these are not the same and
the game knows it juxtaposing the two
against one another to surprising
comedic effect the existential
strangeness extends beyond the
characters themselves of course this is
a turn-based strategy game similar to
other tactical series like x-com but
just barely recognizable in its
presentation where positioning your
forces and choosing when to take cover
or oppress your advantage is key this
time though the positioning gets a
massive upgrade with the addition of
free movement where Kingdom battle used
a grid-based movement system Sparks of
Hope lets you run around the environment
almost as naturally as you would any
Mario platformer complete with its
familiar feeling of momentum this
seemingly minor change has a huge impact
on how the game handles making it feel
smooth and dynamic you can move around
as much as you like until you lock in
place by performing an attack command
and within those boundaries is a
liberating degree of Freedom you can
Slide Attack into enemies organize a
chain of jumps off the shoulders of your
teammates or even just double back if
you think better of your positioning
choices the ability to swap between your
party members means you can go back and
forth between movement and action phases
with Incredible ease it all feels so
natural that I usually didn't even mind
the lack of a jump button heretical as
that may be for a game that feels this
much like a Mario platformer the other
major gameplay enhancement comes from
the titular Sparks themselves these are
swappable equipment types granting the
ability to outfit your troops with
special abilities these can range from
major Elemental attacks to area of
effect Buffs or even more unusual traits
Luigi is specked as a sniper with the
longest range and increased damage for
Far Away shots I equipped him with
ethering a spark that lets you trigger a
temporary cloaking device this felt like
a natural fit for him Luigi's bow grows
weaker when enemies close the gap and
approach him so turning invisible
allowed him to better stay out of The
Fray and at a distance where he can deal
the most damage but I also found it
useful for more than just attacking the
cloaking allowed Luigi to bypass smaller
enemies to get a better vantage point
for high prior priority targets during
boss battles and when the goal was
simply to stay alive cloaking for a
couple of turns brought me invaluable
time to run out the clock Bowser
meanwhile is best at mid-range so he got
exosphere a spark that allows him to
boost defense in an area of effect Mario
is my de facto team leader got Starburst
to boost everyone's attack and uzer
master to generate a slime creature that
effectively added an ai-controlled
companion to our ranks as in the best
tactical combat games some battles are
lost in one in the decisions you make
between rounds as you Tinker with
different spark combinations and plan
how you can augment your strengths or
limit your deficiencies it's a flexible
system that makes your decisions feel
impactful while remaining simple and
understandable like a Mario game should
be there's much more variety when it
comes to exploring the world outside of
combat as well while Kingdom battles
Overworld was colorful enough and looked
the part of the Mushroom Kingdom it was
essentially a straight path and not very
interesting to explore Sparks of Hope
addresses this head on with five open
planets full of environmental puzzles
and optional mini battles Mario almost
takes a page from Zelda in these moments
as the puzzles often revolve around
positioning a block or managing moving
platforms these puzzles help break up
the pace of battle giving you some cool
down time to focus on a different kind
of problem solving they can occasionally
Veer into tedious as you might know the
solution but have to move a widget back
and forth between locations for the most
part though they're a welcome change of
pace the combat is the bulk of the
experience and it's an excellent
refinement on its predecessor combat
environments are well designed to take
advantage of your movement options and
there's a huge variety of enemies that
can be mixed into new combinations of
challenges Sparks of Hope also
capitalizes on the flexibility of its
combat and Spark system by pressing lots
of different kinds of challenges and
boss battles that frequently force you
to think through a new approach or plan
your movements that much more carefully
there's nothing quite like the aha
moment of solving a difficult combat
puzzle and this is a game that delivers
those moments at a regular pace
[Music]
the candy coated Mario wrapping doesn't
come at the expense of ITS Tactical Bona
fides but it is still a Mario game at
heart which means it aims to be
approachable for players of all skill
levels the standard average difficulty
is well suited to those who have cut
their teeth on other tactical games
while the relaxing mode dials it back
while still presenting enough challenge
for novices and the demanding mode is
significantly harder if that still isn't
enough you can tweak individual settings
like how aggressive enemies are whether
health is restored post-battle and how
much if so and even one toggle setting
to make your characters invulnerable to
damage all of this is complemented by a
story that's funny and even shockingly
sweet as the impending Mario movie looms
large as an animated take on the classic
character this game shows you how you
can make a sharp funny Saturday morning
cartoon out of these characters when
Bowser joins the party he says that the
villain cursa stole his army of
imbeciles a laugh line that actually
made me laugh out loud I often found
myself cracking up at the antics of the
characters
even the rabbits in some cases
especially the rabbits I even grew to
love the self-consciously serious hero
Edge and not just because her sword
slinging attack was useful in battle and
objectively speaking badass but I also
felt touched at various moments at one
point even getting Misty at a cheer
Earnest optimism
put simply Mario plus Rabbids Sparks of
Hope is an absolute Delight this is a
combination that shouldn't work and yet
it more than works it excels when
Ubisoft announced Kingdom battle the
concept seems so goofy that its success
came as a surprise Sparks of Hope is an
improvement in every meaningful way from
the characterization and World building
to combat variety and flexibility to
environmental diversity Ubisoft loves
and respects these characters and now
has shown definitively that even
something is familiar and comfortable as
Mario is still capable of surprising us
over and over again
[Music]
foreign